hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in title
Tuesday yesterday between uh Dimitri
andrakin and Magnus Carlsen it's a very
nice game it's a three minute Blitz game
but it teaches us a great value of the
end game but before we check that out a
lot of you uh have expressed the uh well
the the wish to see the the secret games
that were played on the beach between
Magnus Carlsen and uh Han smoking Neiman
and uh if you're wondering how do we
know uh what they played if they are
secret well they were spied upon by none
other than Anish giri and uh here you
can see a nice photo of the two of them
playing some children playing in the
background or maybe it's uh parents with
a child but okay uh here you can see
that there's a there's a position on the
board and it's very hard to make out
what is actually happening however Anish
like I said did spy on them there there
you have it a niche is looking at The
Possession from the distance he even
posted this photo on Twitter he's
enjoying himself you know being under
this white umbrella and he was checking
out the moves and he was able to
recreate two of the games from memory
not the entire games but just the
opening and the important bits uh so I'm
going to share that with you so uh thank
you Anish for uh you know Scavenging
these games for us uh let's let's check
it out and then we are going to check
out the actual game that was played in
the title Tuesday as these games are
only by uh you know a few moves and also
I found that it was um maybe uh quite
quite an enjoyable repertoire with black
if you guys want to use in your Blitz
and bullet games it seems uh it seems to
have uh crushed hunts pretty easily so
you know if you guys want to use it uh
you know feel free to do so so this is
the first game that they showed Hans
played D4 and Magnus played Pawn to the
five nights the C3 and now Magnus played
this Knight the C6 move the the
so-called van geeth opening and as um
Bishop to F4 was played sort of going
for some sort of a London system setup
Magnus just played E5 and he sacrificed
the pawn and after d captures an E5
Magnus played G5 and already now you can
see that this is not your everyday
position Bishop G3 and now Pawn to D4
and if you put this position to any
engine they will just tell you that
black is better so if uh Magnus was able
to get this um uh from Hans
um chances are you will be able to get a
nice position in your own online
Adventures so here Hans played Knight to
the E4 and Magnus even played H5 now
he's threatening H4 to trap the bishop
so Hans played H4 and now Bishop to F5
putting pressure on the Knight
developing a piece and now Knight back
the D2 problem is if you play Knight
captures on G5 then Bishop B4 check and
white resigns there's no move the king
is in check you can't block with the
queen and if you play C3 just the D
capitals and C3 and you even don't care
about a queen trade captures capture
still uh Pawn characters or C2 will be
Checkmate uh pretty pretty scary
position so after Bishop F5 Knight the
D2 was played now Magnus played the G4
and uh this is the the end position that
Annie showed the thing that Magnus uh
won the game pretty easily as it's very
hard to get um
get away for from all of the pressure
black is exerting so this is the first
game and this is now the second game
Magnus again has the black pieces and
again he goes for uh some sort of a
weird setup with Knight to C6 uh Hans
played D4 Knight to C6 Knight to C3 and
now Magnus played Knight to F6 with
Ponte E4 uh transposing into the names
of each defense and now Pawn to D5 E5
and now Knight to D7 sort of offering uh
the D5 Pawn but this is a trick of the
names of each defensive Knight captures
then this very tricky Knight to B8 move
now attacks the Knight if the Knight
moves then you pick up the uh the D4
ponzo black really neutralizes all of uh
White's ideas so instead after 96 we
have Knights the F3 uh and now Knight to
B6 now the pawn is nicely guarded we
have H3 and now Ponte H6 and there are a
few games that reach this position but
after a three by Hans it is and now as
of move seven that we have a completely
new game Magnus played Bishop F5 now we
have Pawn to G4 attacking the bishop
Bishop to H7 and now even Pawn to E6
uh trying to destroy costs and spawn
structure but the Magnus just captures
and after Bishop to D3 yeah Magnus just
captures again Bishop captures Queen
captures and he plays E5 saying he does
not care about Queen to G6 uh check but
really I mean if you don't play this um
E4 is coming so Queen to G6 check King
to D7 by Magnus D captures an E5 and not
Pawn to E6 saying that my king is just
very nicely save here on on D7 B3 by
Hans trying to keep those Knights at Bay
and now Queen to E8 offering a queen
trade Hans goes back he would very much
like to exploit the weak position of the
black king but now Queen to F7 by Magnus
and here Magnus um as reported by Anish
giri is set to Hans Hans you are worse
and sort of uh in in a in a laughing
fashion uh and indeed if if you put this
position to an engine uh the engine will
say that white is worse and that's
pretty much all the moves that Anisha
gives saying that Magnus won this with
black for example a game could continue
if you Castle Bishop to E7 now the Rooks
are coming to f8 you're going to put a
lot of pressure on this Knight let's say
Knight the E2
and after something like Rook 8 f8 even
King to G2 defending the Knight here but
now Pawn to G5 and it is a very very
hard to to play this with white or or
even find the move so very very nicely
done so those are the two secret games
played on the beach I don't know if
there were more of them the two of them
were shown so a big thanks to Anish giri
for revealing them to us very nicely
done now on to the actual game that we
have from yesterday's title Tuesday uh
Dimitri andrekin versus Magnus cross and
let me just uh quickly uh switch this up
uh just give me a few seconds there we
go uh Hans will now magically turn into
Dimitri and they can there we go all
right that takes a bit longer but uh ah
there we have it all right
nice all right so
dimitriandrakin versus Magnus Carlsen
from yesterday's title Tuesday game like
I said it's uh it's very nice because
the the end game the reach is sort of an
elementary end game but they both have
like four seconds on the clock and uh
it's possible for anyone to make a
mistake in in such a situation as you'll
see
uh so andrekin has the white pieces he
opens with D4 D6 by Magnus with E4 and
now G6 Magnus is sticking with the
modern defense Bishop to C4 Knight to F6
with Queen to E2 and now Knight the C6
we have Knight to F3 in the bishop to G4
so all fairly standard stuff Knight C3
guarding the D4 Pawn we have E5 Now by
Magnus and now Pawn to B5 uh striking um
at the Knight pulling pressure on the
center as the Knight is one of the
Defenders or the attackers of the center
and here uh Knight the D7 interestingly
uh there is a game mikhalta played
against Friedrich holafson in 1975 that
style lost where he captures on D4 was
played uh but here we have a different
continuation Knight to D7 Magnus goes
for a different move than top plate even
though he captures Sandy for the move
towel plate is the top move recommended
by the engine uh obviously uh Matt
Magnus knows a bit more and now D
captures an E5 again interestingly there
is a position that Tau reached this time
with the white pieces against Milan
matuna matulovic in Scorpio that ended
in a draw from from 1972 where D5 was
played also a top move recommended by
the engine the one top plate but here we
have D captures on E5 and now Knight D
captures an E5 Knight beta D2 and now
Bishop to G7
so Magnus are ready to Castle here H3
Bishop back to D7 and now both players
Castle so Andre King castles Magnus
castles and now Knight captures an E5
Knight captures and pawn to F for
attacking the Knight and still okay if
Bishop captures on B5 you just recapture
with the queen nothing really happening
there so here Ponte A6 by Magnus uh
Bishop captures on D7 Knight captures
and now and they can wait no longer he
just advances the pawn to F5 and okay
there's no no real threat here you will
get the the openf file for your Rook but
black is very happy with this we have
Queen to E7 by Magnus Quinta F3 and now
Rook 8 to E8 we have Pawn to G4 going
all out against Magnus Bishop to H6 and
now Rook to F2 and this Rook to F2 is
quite a
uh quite a bad move by white but it's
not easy to take advantage of it one way
to do it is just a plainly go g captures
on F5 and now believe it or not
undertaking can resign because if e if e
captures an F5 then just Bishop to E3
and you lose the exchange here uh so
obviously you can't play that you really
don't want to play G captures on F5
because then you open up the G file King
h8 Rook G8 will be very scary and uh
well if you play Queen captures and F5
doesn't really matter because Bishop to
E3 again wins The Exchange so this is
just um uh a very very bad idea but
Magnus misses it he plays D5 which is
not a bad move it's just not uh you know
instant resigns like G captures and F5
and this is a three minute Blitz game
let's not forget so here Pawn to F6
challenge is the queen queen to d8 and
now Queen to G3 uh Knight captures on F6
by Magnus and now Ponte E5 we have
Bishop captures on D2 you could also
play Knight to D7 Magnus goes for Bishop
cap for Sunday too we have Rook captures
and F6 Bishop captures The Rook captures
and now Rook the E6 uh putting pressure
on the
Rook but also just preparing to double
up on the E file Rook Sita F1 and now
Queen to E7 uh getting great to capture
on E5 so here on Drake and traits
captures captures and now Rook the F6
it's the only way to keep putting some
pressure on on Magnus hoping that after
captures captures and captures he can
gobble up the C7 Pawn but Magnus says
Nope not gonna happen Rook capture spawn
captures and now just Queen the C5 with
check not allowing the the capture of
this Pawn King to G2 and now the
spectacular D4 it's a it's a wonderful
move because Magnus is preparing Queen
D5 check and then once uh White deals
with this just uh push the pull the pass
Pawn to Victory so here of course the
pawn must be captured C captures on D4
Queen to C2 with check and now King the
F3 problem is uh okay you could you
could even offer a queen trade but then
just captures captures in G5 stopping
white from uh defending the pawn on F6
now you're just gonna capture the spawn
be up upon and hopefully
I win the game but here we have King to
F3 Queen to D3 check and now and Reagan
goes back King to G2 we have Queen
characters and G3 pretty much the same
idea King captures and now Pawn to G5
now of course uh White cannot play G5
himself and Magnus will win the F6 Pawn
so Pawn to H4 Pawn to H6 captures
captures and now King to F3 we have King
the F7 and now King the E4 so active
King by andrekin but King captures an F6
and now very quickly you will see just
how complicated and simple end games are
Pawn to D5 and now Magnus just plays A5
interestingly A5 the only winning move
for Magnus uh uh you know amongst other
things it stops spawn to B4 uh we have
Ponte a for Bayern breaking and now we
have Pawn to E5 with Ponte B3 just you
know wasting all of the all of the free
pawn moves spawn to B6 and now King to
D3 uh you can't really play anything
else on of the other pawn moves are now
impossible King E7 Magnus needs to put
the King on D6 King back to E3 of course
you can't play something like
just King E4 because then King the D6 in
your auto move so you have to keep
triangulating King the E3 and now if
Magnus were to play King to D6 that
would be a mistake than King E4 and
Magnus is the one without a move so
Magnus of course knows this he does um
uh you know to attend to play the end
game fairly well King to D7 he continues
the the the the dance of kings and now
comes King to D3 and this is now a bit
of a problem because now Magnus can win
this game and he can win this game uh if
uh he plays the only move that wins the
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to win this game for Magnus while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations uh on playing this
uh spectacular uh Pawn push and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pont not C6 but rather Pawn
to C5 this is the move that wins the
game okay if you put the possession to
the engine the engine will say also King
E7 is winning but only because you can
repeat the position and then play key
upon the C5 so here we have Pawn to C5
uh as a winning uh but uh Magnus played
upon the C6 the problem is after King
the C5 white is really without a move
because now after King E4 uh you can
simply play King to D6 now white has to
move and you start gobbling up pawns or
if you don't play this if you play King
to C4 you just don't care King D6 and
now even King B5 will be met with Ponte
E4 and that's it now the pawn will
promote to a queen uh and that's it if
white if white goes back it doesn't
really matter if King to C4 you just
play King to D7 and now if uh well this
is covered this is covered the king
really has no squares here we should go
King back to C3 you can even play King
to C7 and now if you go King to D2 King
to D6 uh well you can go here but then
King captures on D5 and now you you're
up one more Pawn of course now it's
completely winning so here after King to
D3 Magnus did not play C5 Magnus played
C6 and now it's a completely different
story because now Andre can just play
King to E4 and now Magnus is the one
without the move and to make matters
worse he he will not just uh he didn't
just uh you know blunder his winning
chances he will now lose a pawn by force
because now how do you how do you defend
the pawn if you play King D6 just the
characters in C6 and after King captures
King captures and E5 and that's it now
you're you're lost King C5 King to F5
King to B3 you can play King G5 King
Captain B3 King F6 and this Pawn is now
of course much much faster King
characters on A4 g5b5 g6b4 G6 7b3 and
now of course Queen B2 and now Queen T2
check picks up the pawn and wins the
game easily so here Magnus tried to keep
everything together he could still play
C captures on D5 for example and after
King captures on D5 it will it will be a
draw E4 King captures and E for King E6
with a completely symmetrical position
of course now you can just repeat moves
back and forth there's no winning this
but Magnus uh obviously wanted to still
win the unwinnable and now he played C5
a move uh you know after when he should
have played it but not just King
captures on E5 and after B5 and they can
just play eight characters on B5 and he
was in this position and move 45 that
Magnus calls and resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
now whatever you play let's say C4 you
want to create a pass Pawn okay it
doesn't matter A4
uh looks very scary but white just
brings the king back and the white king
is in the square of the pawn uh of
course now there is no you are down two
pawns and the the white king can easily
reach the A4 Pawn it's uh not a problem
A3 King C3 A2 King B2 and that's it
uh so yeah very nicely played by Magnus
another very very nice use of the of the
vanguit opening Trends uh of the uh
sorry of the modern defense
um uh he seems to really be uh you know
putting a very strong Grand Masters in
trouble as uh no one knows how to handle
it properly so I think it might become
very very popular and more and more
player will be playing it online
especially in shorter time format so if
you have uh you know a half an hour in
the day do try and improve
um uh your skill against the modern
defense uh chances are you will be
meeting it quite more often uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it very nicely played by both of them
but uh and in the end okay when uh
Magnus pushed this C6 uh Pawn upon to C6
here both of them were like uh on four
seconds on the clock for five seconds on
the clock but maybe it was even a mouse
slip I don't know because it's very easy
to you know drop drop your mouse and uh
I think out of all the players that play
online chess Magnus is the one with the
most Mouse slips but uh I mean okay uh
it's it's easy to make a mistake in the
end game sometimes your your brain just
convinces you that this is something
that it isn't it happens to everyone and
obviously it can happen to everyone so
yeah very nicely done by andreking hope
you enjoyed this and hope you enjoyed
the the two secret games played on the
beach between Magnus and Hans um uh like
I said really thought you guys might
enjoy uh these uh for example this E5
idea against the London setup uh with
with G5 looks to be is something that
you can use in your online Adventures uh
so yeah and once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Michael Evans for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day